i mean hip bones collar bones like you
really get
railed on that thing you do it i mean
it's such a violent car and
um the other thing talking about just
the violence of it and
in the physical nature you know they run
them on the deck
and dragging the bottom of a cup car is
nothing like dragging the bottom of an
indy car i mean it
literally at times can knock the wind
out of you it's so violent and like oh
no that's that's fine that's normal
like what thing is dragging the ground
pounding the ground
breaking zones you know all that stuff
it's it's a very
it's a beast of a car like i am so
impressed and so thankful i've been able
to create this opportunity
because i don't i don't know if i'll
ever have a chance to drive such a high
performance
car ever again these things are beasts i
believe that each and every one of us
has the power within ourselves to create
the life that we
really want and i want to help give you
the tools
to make that happen i'm danica patrick
and i'm pretty intense today on the show
is an old friend of mine his name is
jimmy johnson
we used to get raced against each other
in nascar
and funny enough now he's racing indycar
he retired from nascar
this last year and now he's venturing
out into the indycar world and doing
road courses which
is such a valiant thing um to go from a
seven-time cup
champion to being humbled to an
indy car and kind of starting over is
just really admirable and
you know jimmy is uh jimmy's a really
smart guy
he's a really he's a really hard worker
and you know that's why i feel like he
is going to
be successful no matter what he does and
we also talked about how
how much how physically demanding an
indy car is to a stock car which is
something i used to kind of
lie to everyone a little bit about not
lie i just omitted how
hard indycar was compared to nascar his
physical
physical fitness which is something he's
super passionate about
uh is something that's being he needed i
mean like i think that if you're not
somebody who has a lot of physical
fitness indycar is a very tough thing
so he's fitting right in and enjoying it
but also you know we talked about life
we talked about you know
perspectives on things and kids and
family and the world today and what's
going on and
then we wrapped up with a nice fun
conversation about burning man so
i ended up finding out that jimmy and i
and his wife shani
um uh we could probably cohabitate
uh so i'll let you listen to the episode
to figure out how enjoy
what do you think of all the stuff going
on did you get into it
that's yeah i mean it's hard not to i
mean
with uh our oldest at 10 she's very
aware of current events
you know it doesn't matter what really
it is oh very much so
um and it's weird how much conversation
really happens in school
and amongst friends you know the kids
are listening to their parents all the
time and it's really
amazing to hear the different points of
views and
very broken information because they're
overhearing conversations
but it's led to um evie picking up the
newspaper we hit the newspaper every day
and i literally have to make sure that
she doesn't
dig in because her curiosity will take
her and she'll ask
very intelligent questions but it just
seems to be there's just too much right
now you know the news is just not a
place for 10 year olds
what do you feel like she what does she
ask you about the most or what does she
say that you're like
her compass is really in the
what's fair category so
racial or social injustice uh current
events
um the white house you know her she's
very curious of where
wright and faire is and i'm very proud
of her for that perspective
and and really big of her you know
obviously at her age at 10.
yeah does she have an opinion i'm
curious what a 10 year old's opinion is
on like
dad this shouldn't be happening or they
should do this
opinions there seem to be less opinions
and more questions
and shannon are quickly diverting the
conversation into
a different direction and maybe we
should spend a bit more time talking
about things but
it really you know her her curiosity
is on the forefront and and her opinions
really aren't there yet she
now my my younger one is probably
different and if she was engaged on this
matter she definitely would have an
opinion
but just evie's mind and the way she
works uh she's just very slow to have an
opinion in general because she wants to
collect all the information first
hmm so interesting because i i mean
like you said maybe shanny and i should
participate in the conversation but then
it makes me think of
how in our world of racing like there
were two things that you just kind of
didn't really deal with and that one of
them was religion and the other one is
politics like you just
stay away yeah and so do you feel like
it's
something that you've always just stayed
away from or just
because of maybe our sort of um
environment
or is that something you're actually
into
yeah i mean i've i've stayed away and i
for professional reasons and also
personal reasons
you know as time goes on the political
conversation
is is harder and harder to have and i
don't mind engaging
i want to make sure that the friends
that i'm speaking to
on the topic you know are willing to
hear both sides potentially
um and and have an open conversation
i mean it's so hard to know where right
or wrong is uh for for many reasons
but i i proceed with caution i
absolutely have my own opinions and
in my own thoughts that go into it all
but
i don't know why i would assume because
of the professional
um structure as you mentioned i've
always been more reserved
in especially the the uh politics
conversation
why do you think that is like why does
racing stay so far away from politics
because ultimately in my opinion we
um you know we are an extension of
the marketing for these given brands and
most brands if not all sell to both
parties or
all parties or all people so taking a
hard stance i think
can put you into um a situation
sometimes but
you know morally at the end of the day
we all have to make that decision if
it's something we feel strong about and
want to stand up for
or have an opinion on and weigh in and
deal with the ramifications
but like has anyone ever really done
that even
i'm trying to think i'm trying to think
if anyone's really like been super
political
i i don't think so i feel like in other
sports especially with the invite
surrounding um a championship and going
to the white house
you know there's been some banter with
other sports you know i feel like
last summer with the social injustice
issues that we had in the country and
nascar taking a stand and drivers taking
a stand
yeah it's probably the the most i've
been in and around or exposed to
anything like that
yeah what was that like when that was
going on because that was a big deal
i mean the whole bubba situation and
i mean i mean i saw obviously i'm
watching from a distance now but what
was it like
what was it like you know pulling into
talladega
and you know the front road uh it turns
into the main
tunnel entrance to see you know
at least 50 cars um
flying rebel flags and trump flags and
you know just just the gathering that
was there
a uh airplane flying low above hand
um i can't recall exactly what the
the banner behind the aircraft was it
was towing by
you know that that was that was pretty
crazy and and that was a moment in time
where i was thankful we didn't have fans
at the track you know there was just so
much going on
and to have that kind of gathering um
there then um was was one piece of it
but when you
worked through the next couple of days
and you know the pull rope in the garage
and
thinking it was a news worrying about my
friend's safety and health
and you know all that just rolled up
into something that on the inside was
was probably far different than what it
looked like on the outside and i know
some on the outside wanted to poke fun
at
it what took place and and not truly
understand what that environment was
inside but inside it was it was not
unlike anything i've ever experienced in
sports
do you feel like as the you know
most accomplished veteran in the series
like you have to do something like was
there a moment where you felt like
maybe i should
i don't know you know i i would say
maybe a week or two beforehand
we came out with a video um that was a
driver initiative
that really spoke to the social and
racial injustice that was going on and
and i certainly felt like i needed to be
involved
there and and had more of a leadership
role
in all of that um then once we we ended
up
in i think it was the atlanta race
weekend is is the time frame of it and
then a few weeks later in talladega
i i went to bubba as a friend and just
texted him and said hey man i'm gonna
i'm gonna stand with you during the
national anthem
uh that was race day morning when i
found out about the news
and that gesture you know others heard
about it others wanted to join before he
knew it
um other drivers had opinions on how to
how to help make that moment more then
team managers were calling and texting
me to figure out how they could be
involved
and then we had that beautiful moment
where the drivers all pushed bubba's car
down pit lane
and the crew members were hopping off
the wall standing and falling in behind
and off the front of the field we went
so uh the first one
more of a leadership role the second
part at talladega was just just being a
friend
yeah that's cool that's really cool um
i always think i think a lot about you
know
i even posted a video the other day on
social media just talking about like the
great divide kind of thing where
you know there's so much stuff in the
world that creates division and it's
you know what do you whether it's shoot
whether it's a race team
a sporting team a color in which you
believe in real
for politics whatever like there's so
many things that divide us and
there you are being a leader to unite
and
like not have a dividing moment and
um put everything on the same playing
field level
visually emotionally and
i mean what do you i mean do you think
about that much
do you do you feel like you want to do
something in that area
do you have an opinion do you do have
you ever felt that
like i don't know i feel like there's so
much stuff to divide us
there really is and there's very little
bringing us together
and i think our um
what's right our stamina um or maybe
tolerance
that we have left um with all that we've
faced as a a country as a world with a
pandemic
um you know adding to the you know the
conversation about the the social
and racial injustice and having a voice
and all that i mean it's
we're all pretty fatigued long story
short and
i i get it and i understand it and i
know that i don't want to be preached to
but i certainly respect and admire those
that
that live their life a certain way and
it's easy to notice that hey they're
they're heading down this road and i i
support that and
as a father i've also learned that my
words
to my kids mean one thing but my actions
mean something far greater
so when i roll that all up i i kind of
feel like that
it something made me say it's the easy
way out but i think that the way that i
live my life the way that interact with
people
the work that my foundation does when i
am comfortable to stand up and talk or
stand up and lead you know handling
those moments through
through real actions and and uh
showing really who i am i think is a
good way
to help use my power my tools
to lead others that are jimmy johnson
fans that are fans of the sport
in a way that you're not lecturing and
beating people over the top of the head
with i mean i think we're just all
way too fatigued to deal with that yeah
so it's kind of about really like
just doing instead of saying there's so
many people that are out there
complaining or
screaming from the mountaintops things
but it's really about like
how do you live your life totally
exactly right and i would only add that
maybe not from the mountaintops but from
the basement of their mom's
house and their underwear social media
stage is a game
it is it can be awful it's very useful
and helpful but it can be awful
you'd probably rather be on the
mountaintop skiing is the only
mountaintop that you're kind of
interested in right
that is so true knee deep powder on the
mountain top
i've snowboarded a couple times um i've
never skied
uh and um powder is definitely better
for snowboarding
oh without a doubt it fell on my ass a
couple times so
hard on um a snowboard
it was like morning time and the slopes
were groomed
so like traversing to a lift to get to
another area and it was like with a
snowboard man have you snowboarded
yeah yeah yeah you can probably do a lot
better job describing this
but i'm like trying to keep my momentum
up and when it gets to the low and
slight the flatter
wider groomed area it's just it's like
rock hard too because it's the morning
and i'm trying like you can't go dead
straight because you'll definitely catch
an edge
definitely and then so i'm like just
trying to turn just enough
but it didn't matter i caught an edge
and i found my ass so hard
like two times in a row and i just
started bawling and i'm in my goggles
and i'm just
bawling and bawling and falling and i
can't even sit down
and that's my experience but i feel like
i want to ski
you know both have their pros and cons
and both are
are you know there's a learning phase
there where you hit the ground often and
it hurts
but i think skis especially ski
technology today has really opened up
and it's easier to
load the ski get it to bend get it to
turn at the same time board technology
has come a long way
and i started off as a skier shandy
turned me into a border
and then once kids came along we've been
back on skis
to help teach them and be with them but
we have we had a rule that if you're 10
you can
you can choose to snowboard and evie has
exercised that option this winter
so now she needs a boarding partner so i
feel like i will end up back on a board
some
but to your point i'm gonna make sure
there's fresh powder down because
a snowboard in the ice or in the bumps
you know
it's really not not not a lot of fun i
felt like
i don't know i felt like a snowboarder
wants like the opposite
of what a um the opposite of a
uh of a skier i mean from a technique
standpoint it's like
a skier wants like a groomed
like not super steep is nice but a
snowboarder
would want like steep and and powder
is that like would that be right yeah am
i just so
bad at snowboarding i have no idea what
i need
no i i i think steep and deep in both
environments is the way to do it
but the right skis are required you know
you need wider skis for the flotation
and it's certainly a lot more work but
from a
you know on mountain or in bounds
perspective
you know most groomers are are more fun
on a set of skis than than a snowboard
a lot just has to do with how important
it is to be on an edge and
on a snowboard you have one edge and
skis you have two and you're kind of
faced the right way to recover and save
yourself but
and we spent a winter out in colorado
maybe three or four years ago
and we were just typical kind of skiers
up until then but
to get a full winter and i think i had
like 85 days to skiing
it really elevated my game and now i can
get around pretty good in anything
what'd you notice from a fitness
standpoint i'm curious because you're
obviously into fitness you're into
training you know especially like
endurance and
um but did you notice a difference in
your body with a lot more skiing
i'm just curious you know i'd say a
couple pieces to it one being at
altitude
um i felt like my my aerobic
cardio output was better when i'd come
back from
being at altitude i didn't feel like the
strength was any better but like the
longer the duration
or just cardio lower heart rate cardio
events were a lot easier
but it was so easy to put on bad weight
it's skiing through the winter
you know just the environment of powder
pancakes on a powder day to
you know an evening meal or whatever it
was just that the cadence of eat i ate
way more
than calories burned so yeah
wow i think of like skiing and i'm like
drinking a bunch of red wine like
steak and red wine every night you know
that's so
so one point right there so what's your
training like now okay okay
obviously i'm gonna have to ask all
about indycar i'm so curious what your
thoughts are and i know you've been
testing a lot um uh and i thought it was
a
a funny also scenario that you know
here you are like retired yet
you're now learning a whole nother craft
which is kind of like another craft
indycars are so different
as you're maybe realizing yes and then i
mean it's still racing but everything's
different within the actual
action and then on top of it you're
retired but now you're actually a school
teacher
shannie's coming and saying hi right now
she's checking oh tell her i said hi
it's danica you want to say hi she can't
see you oh hey danica
hi beautiful now good to see you how are
the girls
they're good she's so wonderful um
but that's a thing right keeping kids
busy
it is i mean and then your patience to
deal with them through school and to be
a good parent and
handle things right you just realize how
critical school is in how teachers are
all saints and so helpful in the whole
thing what do you mean critical school
is
the learning at home from your parents
like
that whole notion of we all know it so
well we may or may not i know i didn't
really want to
listen to my parents all that closely
most kids are probably in that same
thing
so to be taught you know for your
education to depend on that relationship
with your parents is tough
um so it there's there's plenty of
challenges
they don't listen to you no then they
know they can get away with stuff and
they're gonna check
out and you're worried about their
education so there's this interesting
tension and concern where you're trying
to keep them on task and
you know you get through everything
you're not sure they really retained it
and depending on how long homeschooling
lasts
you know you feel like you're kind of
leaving and leaving a mark in their
education as it become older you know
i mean i know they're young and probably
everything at this point is pretty
important but do you think some of the
stuff that they have to learn is kinda
first grade for the youngest one like
last year was kindergarten when we did
did a lot of homeschooling you know but
it was really
not a big concern um but fourth grade
for evie
you know we're more concerned about that
do you feel like it's all valuable
information like i'm just gonna say that
i am not one to advocate for school i
have a ged
i like was gone all the time and
i to feel like i mean you use math you
use
um reading and some critical thinking
um but i'm a little judgmental of school
because
you know i'm doing fine and also
i don't feel like i blew off my
intelligence
and just would throw it away and say
like oh i'm not smart just because
i know i didn't finish school so there's
some basic like historical information
and
a few odds and ends that i just don't
know that most people do
however i've applied myself in so many
other ways that i'm educated in other
ones so
anyway i just think schools i don't know
i don't disagree and i have a very
similar path with you know my racing and
and made it through high school and that
was it
it's wild though when you you know when
you're
the little ones depend on you you just
want to load the gun for their life the
best that you can
so you you end up with this is one of
many interesting pressures that kind of
show up as a parent that
you know i really never thought about
before or thought that i would care
about but as time goes on and you watch
them grow you're like man i want to give
them their best chance
so it's an interesting pressure that
grows
well what's your perspective you said
you have a similar one
you didn't go to college no no didn't go
to college
i tried a couple semesters chevrolet was
nice enough to
um and encouraged me to go to school and
said they would
pay for my tuition if i completed the
course
with uh any class with a you know b
um so i started two semesters and once
travel kicked up
i was i was out and didn't see it
through and that there certainly are
gaps
um you know it hasn't completely
um stopped me from progressing where i
wanted to my career and
certainly having a passion at a young
age and pursuing something with all my
heart
was was most important in you know the
journey my life's taken
yeah so should they go to college
i'm going to encourage it but at the
same time if they're a doctor obviously
we want a doctor to go to college
right maybe a lawyer but i don't know
yeah i mean i'm more interested i think
with my
45 years of living life in having
something i'm truly passionate about
that i hope that they can find that at a
young age
and then that passion will help you know
build the road for what they need to
learn
um ultimately i believe you just you
need to enjoy your life you need to wake
up every day inspired and
peaceful and balanced and certainly you
know there are plenty of challenges
thrown at all of us as life goes on but
it for me having that carrot out there
in front of me the thing i've been
passionate about always kind of guiding
my life
has has really served me well and as a
father i hope to
i hope that my kids can find that as
well what are some of those other things
you do
i mean like you have the passion of
bracing but you know
there's other things there's other
things we can do to be happy those are
the things we can do to stimulate us
um i'm sure you've got other hobbies i
mean other interests and but like what
are your kind of routine things that you
do that you've found
that really put you in the right frame
of mind and make you happy
i would say that i'm i need to be active
and
to physically do things and accomplish
things
to sit down and read a book or
you know find a topic that i'm
interested in and pursue it online
and learn that's that's really not
what i'm inspired to do but if shaney
gives me a honeydew list of
things that need done around the house
i'll jump on the list and i feel
accomplished i'm crossing things off the
list if i'm physical and
doing it so in general that's kind of
the way i'm wired and
clearly racing all the things through my
life that i have has
fit into that box as well the importance
of training
has has ramped up over the years and
certainly
more now that i'm transitioning and indy
cars as you so well now
well know the cars are way way more
physical than a nascar vehicle
and in that whole journey i've i've
realized you know the importance of
nutrition hydration physical activity in
the the benefits that i
pick up from it physically and mentally
i didn't think the mental piece would
come along but
you know the the endorphin release of
training and how that helps my
temperament mindset
feeling accomplished um for me if i get
in that training session i make good
decisions all day long
uh from a health and wellness standpoint
so you know i've that's become a more
critical part of my life
as i've grown older and shaney as well
and we're trying to figure out how to
kind of
create those meeting points where we can
do that stuff together
if it's skiing or cycling i'm trying
yoga occasionally which
i'll send you a photo you'll die it is
not uh
it's not my thing but if we can do it
together and i know it's helping me
we'll
we'll try it so you know i'm a doer at
the end of the day
yeah shanny likes yoga yes
she is a natural i mean her flexibility
she actually gets in trouble
with the yoga instructors that she's
like gone past the point
of the muscle hold and she's like
counting on a joint to hold her up she's
that flexible
i know those people and i want to flip
them off when i'm in class i'm like gosh
just because your shoulders and your
hips have no joints whatsoever
i'm over here like you know feeling like
you know because i've
sat like this my whole life i'm like can
my shoulders just
open up a little bit your shoulders
tight i bet your shoulders oh my gosh
so tight yeah and then the new workout
program is not helping that any either
okay so you said it i mean when i came
to in when i went to nascar people were
like
how are you gonna handle that big car
physically and i'm like
i actually kind of bit my tongue
and didn't say how much easier stock
cars were to drive than nascar because i
thought if people want to give me credit
for
being off able to handle these big cars
and so hard
i'm just gonna let them think that i got
it um
i mean i said it but i didn't make a big
deal about it but it's
true like what have you experienced
the you know there's many pieces to it
but
depending on the track and the steering
wheel load and and clearly
you're hanging on to the steering wheel
so forearms
arms and general shoulder uh that stuff
seemed pretty logical to me and
obviously the neck but i didn't realize
just the true importance of core
strength of back strength lower back
strength
that's been something i've been working
really hard on and after my
two test sessions last year um i i was
pretty sore
afterwards and i tested a car two days
ago and i feel great and i've been back
in the gym working out so
i'm making the right gains there but it
was at sebring two days ago and the
thing that was so impressive to me with
these cars
is the intensity and a lot of my
training has been
shorter duration and a lot higher
intensity compared to what i did for
nascar
and i can see why i mean you know
bristol and to me i've been telling a
couple friends that have
from the nascar side that have asked
post test what what i think
and driving that indy car is like
qualifying at bristol but
every lap in every corner i mean you are
so committed
you're 10 10 the whole time and the car
can take it which is just wild
that was what i always said about an
indy car was that
its pure potential is so far beyond what
you think it could do
that's the hardest thing is like getting
all the way to that edge
believing that you're like wait a minute
you mean i could possibly go
flat around richmond in an indy car you
know you're like
and just when the wheel loads and gets
heavy like you think
i mean there's so much feedback coming
through the wheel i mean just about like
the weight of it
and i don't know about you but the
weight of it always translated to
um like being loose
like oversteer as you're learning the
terminology oversteer understeer
trying i'm failing miserably thank you
with it
it gets confusing right because that's
the thing is like
again you're driving a race car but
there's so many things that are even
opposite where
like in a in an indy car you're talking
about
understeer overseers talking about the
front of the car and when you talk about
it in nascar you're talking about loose
and tight and a lot of times
loose like you're talking about the back
of the car and so i mean it's just
there's a lot of differences
but um but yeah there's no power
steering and
for sure how about the belts have you
because
i mean that was one of the things when i
got back in the car for the 500 to do
that last race in my career
um i was like [ __ ] i forgot how tight
the belts have to be
yeah you can't get to them i mean they
they
uh i wish the lot belt could be a little
tighter um
oh they can make them tighter they can't
but the guy can't get them buckled well
we were just dealing with that at the
test session you know they have to put
all that on for you and
yeah you got to exhale you got to sink
your body um
yeah my suits right now have pockets on
them and that extra material is the
problem why they couldn't clip it
so well oh yeah so i remember that too
when i would get in the car
and then since also because it's hit so
hard on your hip bones
that you um like i would pull the pocket
of my suit to the middle so that it was
smooth over my hip bones and then since
the center is kind of a little bit more
space in there than on the actual hip
points where the act where the belts hit
that's what i would do with the pockets
take that advice and put it into play
i appreciate it yeah because i mean
that's the thing too
is like i mean hip bones collar bones
like you really get
railed on that thing you do it i mean
it's such a violent car
and um the other thing talking about
just the violence of it and in
the physical nature you know they run
them on the deck and
dragging the bottom of a cup car is
nothing like dragging the bottom of an
indy car i mean it literally at times
can knock the wind out of you it's so
violent and they're like oh no that's
that's fine that's normal
like what thing is dragging the ground
pounding the ground
breaking zones you know all that stuff
it's it's a very
it's a beast of a car like i am so
impressed and so thankful i've been able
to
create this opportunity because i don't
i don't know if i'll ever have a chance
to drive such a high performance car
ever again
these things are beasts
why like why did you decide to do it
because like it's a big feat
i mean you can see why maybe it's a
little bit more normal to go from
indycar to nascar than nascar to indy
car
yeah intensity like it's super hard to
be good in a stock car
don't get me wrong if it was that easy
i'd have won everything and i didn't
um but it's just like the it's just like
something about it is
like you said it's so intense sweet
spots in different places
you know i mean sure it's a car but
they're they're really different
um and for me i mean i've always wanted
to be an indycar driver as a kid growing
up
and yeah after driving fernando's
formula one car a few years ago when we
did the swap
i was like i've always wanted to do this
this experience
only made me want to experience more and
i started the process
and i was surprised to see there was
interest
and amongst the teams and then from
there it was like all right well if we
can get some sponsorship put together we
can pull it off
i was able to get carvana in the mix and
put them on the car
so so here we are and i i am not
expecting
the type of success i had in cup but
i am um really trying to tell myself and
of course the competitive side's going
to kick in and i'm
i'll be sad plenty next year or this
year but
the experience to do this is really
where
my heart is i've always wanted to to
race one of these cars and be in the
paddock
any word that i learned and be around
this this industry
and who really gets that opportunity i
mean some of my heroes
when i was a kid would move back and
forth you've been one of the few that
moved back and forth daario um there's
only a handful of people
that have ever been able to experience
both and where i sit today that's
something that's really important to me
it's something that i'm very glad to be
a part of
um what do you i mean if you were to i
mean
like of course like you said your goal
is to win
you're not going to be doing it you're
not doing it because you're like i don't
actually want to win i just
love to be 11th but outside of that
do you feel like you can have what are
your realistic goals
i mean winning is possible for sure
you're jimmy johnson but
it's going to be hard now there i mean
anytime you line up you've got to
believe
that you have a shot to win or else it's
not worth going um it's just not how
many of us are wired
right you know right now i'm trying to
really remind myself
of my early days in racing and and i've
i am starting over for all intensive
purposes and i
found a lot of um
peace of mind when i tried to crawl
before walk walk before run and just
keep it that basic and simple
and right now my goal is to get within a
second of scott dixon when we're at a
test session at the track
and i'm super close like i if one of
these typical things if i would have
completed the lap and didn't spin
i would have been a half second off of
them but uh i didn't at sebring when i
was there a couple days ago and i'm
right about a second off the pace
and when i look at november where i was
that was three seconds off the pace
so a little bit of dpi testing a lot of
formula three driving
trying to go to these tracks trying to
kind of forget the nascar piece and
rewire
myself to a formula car i'm making
progress
and i have a lot more driving set up
between now and the start of the season
and um
you know hopefully i can get in that
that's i feel like once i get in that
second
window then the car set up
my conversations with teammates the
engineering meetings like i can be in
the conversation then
at three seconds off the pace where i
was in november
i you know they just need to keep
putting tires on the car and let me go
like i shouldn't be a part of the
of helping steer the team and providing
data and input
so that's really the first objective for
me is to get to that point
yeah i think this is kind of applicable
across the board for people that
i mean shoot right now of all times in
the history like people are making so
many transitions
and your perspective on like how to
approach
that being so successful in one area
going to another
is i think really valuable for people
yeah there there is a uh a moment here
um you know i've been working on a few
projects to kind of document
all of this that's going on just just
because it is an interesting perspective
and
many are kind of going through that
stuff um been recording
and collecting um content for
probably 18 months now knowing that my
final year was coming and this hopeful
transition
and working on a docu series and then i
have another picture book that we're
putting together and working on now to
kind of document that as well
i'm really not into books so amongst all
you know
i've had a ton of pressure to write a
book autobiography or something
i'm just not there yet i'd rather do it
through images or video at this point
but
um it is an interesting journey and
there's going to be plenty of failures
you know i think many people think
um you know my cup career and all the
success that i had that it's just been
this
you know easy come you know situation
for me and
there certainly is a start to all of
that trying to make my way into the cup
series the success that i then had
and then this kind of rebuild of sorts
or
uh i don't know what you quite call it
but kind of starting over you know i'm a
45 year old rookie which is wild
in a few different ways i mean you'll
eventually be fully retired but for now
you're doing something new
what i mean do you have something you're
scared of like is there something you
feel like man
if this happens i'm it's gonna be a
difficult one for me to deal with are
there fears
making this transition and being i mean
essentially vulnerable
yeah i mean i i think we're all fearful
of
not being successful or being
competitive so i think it's it's really
in my head to
to determine what that is and not care
what others
might think you know if i if i choose to
check in on social media on my phone
um there's plenty of opinions there that
could could bother me
um so it's really about being in tune
with myself and my team and my sponsor
on this this journey and what this is
really about
and you know the experience that i'm
i'm hopeful to have i think there's a
there's a great story and all that and
one that many can identify with that
that's
actually a bit more rich than just you
know i'm here to win races and
uh we had a bad day but we'll be back
next week i mean there's there's a lot
more to what i'm trying to do
and uh i hope i can find that voice and
articulate that along this journey does
the sponsor have some
i mean you mentioned the sponsor and do
they have some additional role other
than just sort of being along for the
ride and
and seeing an opportunity like you're
kind of experiencing it now a little bit
more from my perspective where it's like
it's such a story that the roi exists in
the story
you don't have to go win for them to
benefit
is there some bigger role that they're
playing or is this
um or is this just what's helping it may
be possible
at all yeah i think the founder ernie
garcia jr
picked up on that quickly with our
conversations that we had
he mentioned it was similar to jordan
trying to
leave basketball and go play baseball
and
how marketers probably wish that they
could have been a part of that journey
somehow and and couldn't and weren't
but here here you can so
carvana has not been in motorsports
marketing in the past so
you know as a growing car business and
trying to get to car people
my demographic fits their core
demographic very well there's a lot of
synergy
there but but most importantly um you
know the
executive staff loves the story and they
they can see and understand the power in
that story
so they really understand for all the
right reasons
well i'm sure you'll get an opportunity
to talk to them a little bit more
directly which is
you know i mean people need inspiration
right now people need
stories people i mean right i mean look
at how we watch
the the jordan documentary look at how
we watch the tiger documentary
we're all looking for a story five years
ago but yeah that was just uh when the
pandemic started we all got it wasn't
even a year ago
can anyone believe that tiger king was
like
nine months ago right or something so
much longer
oh my god so much life has happened um
so um have you heard from chad
yeah we stay in touch he's actually
helping
action express uh the car the team that
i'm driving for on the rolex 24.
we need a few experienced kind of crew
guys to come down and pick what so he's
on your car
he's going to be there um kind of
watching and taking it all in and then
also helping bring in i think four other
bodies to to crew the car for the
weekend so he's crewing your car
yeah yeah and he's crew chiefing your
car or engineering your car what would
you call it in sports cars is it
engineering more of a second or third
engineer well for those people who don't
know
i mean you know uh chad canal says
jimmy's crew chief for ever how many
years is he recruiting
17 17 seasons yeah and then he just left
you high and dry for those last couple
years
no we weren't getting along so well on
those really tell me about it
this sounds like a breakup it was a
breakup
it really happened you know reflecting
back on it i think we both wish
we handled some things differently um
just in every breakup right you know we
we
we operated at a level um
that you know i guess you could argue
that no one has in the sport in nascar
before and executed at a certain level
and that that came at a price
you know it really took you know a lot
of people say they're all in but it took
everything out of both of us
and as as time went on and we both kind
of grew in our
our ways um you know i think we tried
too hard to stick to the model that
used to work instead of growing together
and finding a new way to do things
and that put a lot of tension between us
and eventually
you know mr hendrick had asked himself
you know do i want these two
yelling at each other on the radio week
in and week out television and radio
playing those clips
the performance isn't there you know and
then we're with stuck with that tough
decision
and and split i guess at the end of the
18th season
you got to take my role for the eclipse
of swearing then you got to take it over
from me on that what is that called
after the nascar weekends
radioactive yes i always heard from uh
uh ricky when we used to date like that
he hated me swearing and i was
on radioactive all the time apparently
swearing i didn't really listen to him
but i heard i made
i made the cut most of the time so i'm
so glad that they found you and chad
that you could um fill in that gap
yes yes i'm glad to take over for it
means we have a very
interesting vocabulary i believe um
do you feel like there was something
that you because you said
you know i wish i would have handled
things differently you know i think that
whether it's our personal relationships
or
i mean it's hard to not call you and
chat a personal relationship but a
professional relationship
i mean we learn a lot from these
interactions with our partners and
family and and all these people i mean
what was that
thing that you came away from with that
sort of as you know you call like a
breakup on some level
um was there something you learned from
it that
was really really valuable yeah i think
my takeaway was i need to speak up
earlier and more often
and with his personality and really what
the job
entails for a crew chief you know they
have to boss everybody around all the
time
and crew chiefs get really comfortable
with that and
the lines that they're that they cross
in that process of leading
hundreds of people day in and day out
dealing with the good and the bad
like there's a point where i i i would
be told something or hear something that
i didn't like and i
i'd carry that around with me and then
i'd maybe say something back knowing i
could push a button
on his side and then you know there's
just this thing that would kind of
happen
so i wish that i would would have said
more
said more and said it more said it say
it earlier instead of letting it build
to a point where i'd explode and then
you know and then put him on his heels
it just the timing of that was all bad
so
addressing things earlier and being more
communicative communicative
would be uh would be the takeaway do you
see that showing up like at home
too totally it's we want to believe that
we um
compartmentalize things but we really
are creatures of habit and handle
those situations all the same it's so
true
yep i think i mean yeah i mean it's
you can't get away from patterns yeah
it's just it's how we're wired you know
it's just who we are and
it doesn't mean you can't work on those
things and learn and grow and
and change but you have to spot them and
recognize them first before you can make
those changes
have you ever done therapy yeah
something plenty
[Music]
that was part of the discovery in in
understanding honestly that there's
i always thought there was this
professional life not i just behaved
that way over here at work
no it's on both sides of the fence hmm i
just think that that's such a topic that
like i mean shoot i've got two
therapists right now like i mean i've
gone through waves of it i spent a lot
i spent a good chunk of my i spent an
early part of my life with therapy
then i was like [ __ ] therapy
and then and but really what i ended up
finding was that
you need to do therapy for yourself not
for so much the dynamic when you fix
yourself you fix the dynamic which is
why you say you can't
go fix it for the chad situation because
it shows up with shanny right like
you can't go fixing it for like between
the two of you it's
actually just you and you yeah did you
i mean i found that when i you know
being single and like
doing therapy i was like wow this is so
much more productive to do it for myself
yeah no it really is i completely agree
with you it's a self thing
um i i feel like two were
you mentioned you know it's kind of come
and go for you and your life and it has
for me too and i think
you know you got to go out and live a
little and and have some stuff happen
and then for myself i've been able to
learn more on the back end instead of
just constantly
being checked in and going you know
going through the motions it's nice to
go out and live a little
and then check back in and kind of
evaluate what goes on i've had more
success with that pattern than
than the more consistent way yeah well
it allows you to kind of uh
enjoy the level you've reached of like
cohesiveness or
calmness or peace instead of just always
feeling like there's a carrot out there
um but i think that therapy's super
productive and i just feel like it's not
something that people talk about a lot
you know it's not like people are waving
their flag going you know
i have a therapist i just got out of
therapy i was crying for an hour
ooh do you cry are we one of those guys
that cries
no i can yes it's pretty rare but i can
um i'd love to give jeff gordon a hard
time whenever
something something big happens his eyes
well up and he cries so
i'm very thankful that i can harass him
and i have not had that happen
throughout my my career especially up in
those public moments
you remember that his first win cried
like a baby when he got out of the race
car
oh my god i was like two i don't know
so first banquet like there's some
different moments if you go
go on the uh now i'm going to go on a
google search of jeff gordon crying
you'll see plenty wait but you said you
like i'm glad that wasn't me
so you don't want to cry yeah i guess
maybe it's just being a guy where i was
like
raising her driver does not look tough
you know glad that wasn't me
type thing so you basically just said
jeff does not look tough
he did not most moments no and he would
admit that too
um like along that same vein
are there some things that you've
realized like from your own sort of
childhood and if you're in therapy
there's no doubt you're going into
childhood there's no doubt that you're
going into
parenting how your parents parented you
i mean are there some things that you
feel like have stuck out where you're
like man
these are some things that i i'm gonna
do differently with my kids
yeah there's definitely things that you
reflect on
and you know the the one that comes to
mind
the quickest is the dynamic that's put
on
parents and children when their kids are
in sports and it probably applies to
other things
but my parents did everything that they
could for their kids to pursue motor
sports
and you know things worked out the best
for me and
what people naturally think with the
success that i've had
and you know that that didn't come at
the expense
of of some peace
with my parents you know they
they did everything they could to give
me these chances and these opportunities
but at some point in time
they had a hard time of letting go and
letting me be me and letting me get off
on my own
um you know of course i had my parents
employed
working for me and there was the
uncomfortable moment in time of like
hey mom and dad i'm gonna do something
different right so
that whole piece um you know i hope that
i'm in a similar situation where i give
my kids everything that they need and
their their career is taking off and
they have to say hey dad you know
i got it and i then in that moment you
know i think there's
learning on my side in advance going
into it and then i need to pick up on
some cues
um from my own experience if they don't
if they're not able to tell me to you
know hey dad step back type thing so
that dynamic comes to mind the quickest
yeah so
true i think in racing two it's also a
little bit more difficult because
there's no natural transition you don't
go to college
you don't like you know what i mean
there's no um
there's no severance of a pattern they
stay engaged and so
i did the same thing i hired my parents
and honestly i wouldn't even change it
because it's the best decision i could
make i didn't know who to trust back
then
right but then i had to fire him that's
never fun
and that's not fun no at all so
yeah and you know again kind of like
maybe therapy there's these ebbs and
flows of like you know there's so much
freedom and you know remember the days
and you get to ride your bicycle
wherever you want
and now it's like only if i'm riding
next to you and we're going to the end
of the cul-de-sac and back
and you don't get training wheels off
until you're at least a teenager and
you know there's the more the helicopter
kind of parent sort of mindset and just
the fear of the world being
so scary out there and you know maybe
now we're kind of entering a phase kind
of like
you know in a lot of other ways where
we're getting more holistic even or more
natural with our
remedies for things and food and farm to
table like
things are kind of going more grassroots
again and a little bit more freedom and
a little bit more
um yeah just kind of going
like regressing but in an aware way
yeah we're on that pattern especially
with
shannie's upbringing and kind of what
she's plugged into and naturally drawn
to
um and in my experience the woman really
leads the household so
uh shanny's maternal ways and just
her awesome vision and in presence
in in trying to help us all be healthy
mind body and soul you know her layers
of all that
are helping us and we're trying hard not
to be the helicopter parents
and i find that you know our summers in
colorado or the time we spend in
colorado really
lets us kind of step back and let and
give them more freedom and let them be
you know be themselves much more and
have that freedom that that we really
did as a kid growing up
yeah that makes me think of something i
wanted to ask you about just because of
how long you were in nascar and watching
sort of the arc of this
like i'm gonna call it like helicopter
fans right like
you know it went from being this you
know it went from the old days of
freedom and you could do what you wanted
there was no social media
you know no drug testing there was no
cameras everywhere there's you know
there's just i mean there's shoot
no pit road speed limit at some point in
time like
i mean there was so much more there was
so much more freedom
and decision that could be made and i'm
super curious about
like what what was your first year in
nascar
first first year in cup or first time
ever in a nascar vehicle
like in cup even or just or bush or
would it be called bush then
well so my first bush race was in 98 and
my first cup race was in 2001.
yeah so even like from 98 you're still
kind of living that life
right what was it like in those late 90s
versus like what could you guys what was
a normal weekend like
that for me was really kind of the era
of
all the teams staying in a host hotel
you know in a way or
a couple hotels around the track and
you knew the local spots to eat the
local watering holes
and it was pretty simple the garage
closed and
you went and grabbed a shower and then
you'd go run into various crew guys that
were just
out you know and you'd be out and you
know try to behave well rotate some
waters through
try to have somebody there to send you
home when it was time
and uh sleep it off and show up and go
again
and it was much more simple back then
and even
at that point in time for me you know a
lot of it was driving to races
it wasn't even flying let alone flying
on your own planes so
um it was a far different environment
do you think it was more fun
it was for me because of the age
it was my life and it was a lifestyle
so i had an absolute blast yeah there
was
no way i could have been married or
started a family
or been a good father in that period of
time just because
i mean not only were you gone on the
weekends but a lot of this drive time to
and from races
the amount of testing that was able to
take place back then
um you're never home you're gone so i
wouldn't be the husband
or the father that i'd want to be just
because i'd never be home yeah
yeah yeah what else was different back
then i mean i just feel like it was a
whole different world
oh no soft walls no hans device
flimsy aluminum seats you know when you
when you hit something
uh there were a lot of us playing hurt
when you hit something you were hurt
from a concussion
broken sternums broken collarbones
shoulders wrists
i mean you played hurt quite a bit back
then that's why you had to drink
yeah because you were in such pain you
were all the time
[Laughter]
um what are some i mean what are some
fun things that you do
like now like i don't know it's hard
even to say that because you're so like
not retired but
were there are there things that you
want to do or things that you can
imagine wait a minute how did i miss
this
you went to burning man i did yes oh my
god i want to know because i want to go
it is it is worth going to you can tell
me
what other people did tell me what
other people did so when i
the following burning man i we had a
race in darlington
and i i told the nascar folks i'm like
do you guys just want to cut the chase
now and send me the drug screening
trailer straight away
like is that the move um but it was
um way bigger than i imagined
um i think the year we went base
you know they still out all the time but
they allowed 75 000 people
to to be on the playa we arrived on
uh opening day and stayed till midweek
so we really caught the kind of
calm side where the camps are being
built and assembled is there's really a
week
you come in and set up and then you're
out and you can leave no trace
so we were there i feel like more with
the true burners and the people that are
are there for
the the experience more than the
instagram picture uh so we we missed
that back half
when the place was at capacity and the
burn and all the other stuff that went
on but
what a what an interesting day i mean we
were there i think three days
and we'd wake up in the morning and fill
our camelbacks full of water
get on our bikes right
and off you go bring plenty of stuff to
barter
a little bit of dancing um and just
explore
i mean we found a roller skating rink
out in the middle of the playa
i mean just you name it there anything
you think that could be built is there
and it's all just to chill hang
experience with one another
is fantastic would you go again without
a doubt
right definitely should go
i'm not sure with coven i don't think it
happened last year and i
there's some rumors that it's had a
tough time surviving which i don't
understand why
um you know without having the financial
piece moving along
uh so hopefully it's still around and
and uh whenever covet goes away
i will be one of the first in line to
get a ticket
um did you learn because i feel like one
of the things about burning man is just
how
um you know it's kind of a spiritual
experience
it can be whatever you want it to i mean
i literally on our bike ride exploring
went by a family area where there were
these amazing
playsets for families to to camp and
play and
they were having their experience you
get closer
uh to the to the man and up on this one
side of the playa
definitely the party side um our camp
fortunately was over on the quiet side
and
you know we would we were all ready to
party but we would kind of mount up on
our bicycles and ride to it to go
you know experience and then kind of
come back and retreat and get sleep
but the uh the thing that was so cool is
just the energy
and to be around so many people of the
same mindset
and so free uh there's an experience
there
that um you know if i hear here's some
of the house music that plays from
from burning man i can kind of bring
that feeling back and remember it
but it is so ever present when you're
there just the energy of all these
people
when you you just said other people of
the same mindset
and i would say that like that would be
my jam
i would love to go there that's why i
love to go to places like tulum and i
like to go to
sedona or whatever it's this sort of
high vibe energy
openness positivity like you're not
talking about politics you're not
talking about those kinds of things
you're really
so i feel like you saying that makes me
feel like i know you better
good it you would you would totally dig
the place too but yeah that that
uh that ex that energy experience and
that that same mindset was
the huge takeaway for me it was awesome
so maybe we all just need to basically
become burners if the world became
burners
don't you think that would solve
everything it would and when you see
it would be a good start when that
city that pops up over a week and
how everybody interacts and gets along
you really nobody mentions last names
you know that
status kind of disappears and
it's all inclusive and you can use a
barter system and trade
trade along the way to food drink
whatever it might be
that uh you just see how this community
works it's really inspiring and uh
and teaches you to open your heart i've
often thought that
i keep i've been saying it for years
about starting a commune
and like all the shit's hitting the fan
everywhere and i'm like we just need to
start a commune
if you were if you were in the commune
if we were in a commune together
i i like to ask people what would your
talent be what would you what would you
bring to this commune because you have
to bring something like i would be a
trainer
i'd like to be the gardener and a chef
and i could use some help like you know
me and someone else could handle
for sure the kitchen but like what would
you bring to the commune
yeah i would try to join you in the
training piece and maybe
do mountain biking or cycling you know
some kind of cardio
activity oh good you can leave you can
be like the lance armstrong of our group
you can be the cardio king you can be
the endurance guy
yeah i'll be the hit trainer there you
go
what would shanny bring uh she would she
would probably want to be your yoga
be in the yoga squad i would say and in
cooking and also gardening her mom
her and her mom and then now genevieve
as a result our oldest
they just have a certain thing about
them with their green thump
and they're always cooking um we have a
garden here in the backyard and
evie will be out there kind of working
in the garden tending things
so that she would help you there jimmy i
had no idea how cohesive
i was with your family but it sounds
like we could live in the commune
evie and i would get along little rebels
that like to ask a lot of questions
um and um we'd just be like the health
and fitness gurus
that's it be healthy and good okay i'll
let you know
when it opens perfect
until then good luck in indycar thank
you i'm so excited for it i'm gonna be
cheering for you
a lot i really like i really hope you
have
a fun experience and part of that will
be
you know having a decent result
and i'm gonna hope that that happens
like i want you to want you to come away
having a lot of fun
because like i had a lot of fun in
nascar and i had some decent results
here and there
and um you know you in fact i don't
doubt you will you're going to have a
great experience
i appreciate it it's all about the
experience i'm going to have fun
yeah yeah be careful for the grip
strength though yeah the little things
your phone
a magazine like carrying your luggage in
any way
like those are the little things that i
remember worrying about in indy car
then i didn't think about it all in
nascar
yeah i'm definitely um my
what's crazy is just to see how much my
body's changing obviously in the process
i've
never had forms before and they're
they're starting to show up now
power steering was nice for all those
years oh i know that's what i said i'm
like
guys the indy cars didn't have power
steering you know yeah
you're like i'm starting at three to
minus three degrees caster and i'm up to
minus two degrees caster
slowly chipping away at it yeah yeah
yeah well good luck
cool thank you danica thank you thanks
everybody for listening to the pretty
intense podcast today i hope you enjoyed
it
if you like what you heard today and you
want to hear more please click on the
subscribe button